in this video we'll see a more general
algorithm for performing inference in
general conditional random fields known
as belief propagation so we've seen in
the previous video that we could
visually illustrate a undirected
graphical model like a conditional
random field that can be written as a
product of factors into a factor graph
where we have a graph with notes that
correspond to random variables and other
nodes that correspond to the different
factors in the model one advantage of
the factor graph is that it provides a
good representation for actually
deriving and illustrating the types of
computations that we must do to perform
inference in a undirected graphical
model like a conditional random field in
fact the forward-backward algorithm that
we've seen before for computing the
Alpha and Beta tables which are useful
for necessary to computing marginals in
the linear chain conditional random
field can be written in the more general
form where in it's a specific case it
boils down to the forward backward
algorithm but for a general conditional
random field it provides now an
algorithm for these more general cases
or performing inference specifically
believe pilot so this algorithm is known
as belief propagation it's a message
passing algorithm in the sense that now
in the graph each node the nodes are
going to exchange messages between them
and the messages are going to be
exchanged normally until convergence
that is until the messages that one node
is sending to another node does not
change and the idea is that the messages
that one node is going to send to
another node is going to be a
combination of things that come from the
factors associated with that node and
messages that were received from its
neighbors so there are actually going to
be two types of messages much like there
are two types of nodes in the factor
graph there are going to be two types of
messages
so there are going to be messages from a
variable node which are illustrated as a
circle in the graph to its neighbor
factor nodes which are the squares the
messages they are going to be defined in
a recursive form so the message from a
variable node which is illustrated is
noted s to a node that is a factor so we
use F to illustrate factor nodes so the
message from s to F when the node s
takes value I is just going to be the
product of the messages that all the
other factors F prime which are
connected to s and that are not F so the
node F will not send messages
recursively to itself so it's going to
receive the messages that other factors
F prime have sent to s fourth again the
where we assume that the node s is
taking value I so we take all the
messages that have been sent to s and we
multiply them together and that becomes
the message that s is going to send to F
and when we take the product of fad of
messages we only take the messages from
factors F Prime's which are not F but
our neighbors are connected to s okay so
in this illustration here the message
from s to F is going to be the product
of the messages that come from this and
this node this factor node here in this
factor note here so this would be one of
the F Prime's and so will be another F
prime and now the message is from a
factor node to a neighbor variable node
it's going to be slightly more
complicated so the message from F to s
where s takes is assumed to take value I
so for instance in if s is a label node
then I would be a potential label for
that that label node is going to be now
not just a product by the sum so we can
have a sum over the value of all the
other variable
that are involved in the factor f the
factor that's sending a message but
where in this sum will keep the value of
the node s2 which we're sending message
to its value we're assuming which is I
which is this here so we take the value
of the factor for all vectors Z where
all the values of all the other
variables involved in this factor are
being changed to their potential value
which right of all these values except
for the note S which we keep fixed to I
and when you take that value we also
multiply the messages that all the other
neighbor nodes and so the neighbor nodes
here are going to be variable nodes as
Prime's that are neighbors of F except
the node to which we're sending a
message s so we're going to multiply all
all the messages that these nodes S
Prime's have sent to F and where us also
take into account in this sum what is
the value that that a node s prime is
taking in the variables involved in the
factor so visually the message sent from
this factor to that variable node is
going to involve the messages that came
from all other variable nodes that are
not s and it's going to be the product
of these messages but then they're going
to there we're going to get a message
for each potential value that each of
these variable node can take and they're
going to be combined together and
weighted by the factor associated the
sort of factor that is sending the
message and we're going to sum over all
potential values that these this
variable known and this variable node
could take so to make this more concrete
we're going to do the specify specific
case of a linear chain CRF and it's
going to be simplified so we won't have
a context window we'll just have y1 be
connected to x1 and y2
only 2 x2 so here we have our equations
for the messages and now we'll do a few
iterations of the messages when we
compute a few of them and actually we'll
pull in this example only two from left
to right for now so first we initially
we initialize all the messages to 1 so
the new message is all going to be set
to 1 initially that's usually the
starting condition we use now let's
consider the message that is sent from
x1 to this factor so a message from a
variable node to a factor node should be
the product of all the messages that the
variable node has received from other
factors except F now in this case X here
is only involved in one factor so there
are no other messages so in this case
we'll the product of nothing we'll set
it to 1 by definition next we'll
consider this message here from this
this factor to that variable node so if
we look at the formula here from a
factor to a variable node what we have
to do is that we have to sum so ok so
this factor involves y1 and x1 and then
while what we have to do is to sum over
all values involved in the factor that
is x1 and y1 except that we keep the
value of the node to which we're sending
the message so that's s2 it's specified
value in the message so that's I here
and also we only sum over the variable Z
that are unobserved so in this case X 1
is given so we keep it fixed also to its
given value so in fact in this case we
have only one term in the sum and that's
the term where x1 takes the specified
value and y1 takes also it's the value I
so removing the Inc the message being
sent to y1
from this factor is going to be the
value of the factor for x1 and some
given while you value of y1 being equal
to I so that's this term times the
message that was received by this factor
from other value variable nodes than y1
so the only other message is this
message here which is 1 so 1 times that
because this will be the expression of
the message and notice that when I say
that I say for a given value I for the
variable node it means that I need to
send what this message is for all values
I of the variable node in question so in
this case when I'm sending a message to
y1 it can take as many values as the
number of classes from 1 to see so we
need to compute this expression for I
being 1 2 3 up to capital C so when I'm
sending this I'm can I can think of it
as sending a vector actually where each
element of the vector is a different
value of the message for different
values of I and so I could just take the
exponential of the log unary factor for
all value possible values for I 1 and
send that as the message of this factor
to the variable node y1 then we have to
send message from y1 to this factor so I
have a message from a variable node to a
factor node assuming that our variable
takes some given value I and that needs
to be the product of all messages that
were sent to the factor 2 the factor
sorry - the variable node F except s
sorry except F so in this case the other
message that could have come in from
other factors would be this message so
we'll have the product of just this it's
the only other factor message that this
is receiving except from
message from this guy this factor note
so the message sent by I y1 to this
factor would just be the exponential of
the unary factor for the value of y1
which would be I so we have the vector
of exponential of au 1 exponential au 2
and so on this vector would be sent to
that back factor next we have the
message from this factor no to that
variable node so that's this role here
now we have to sum over all the values
of the random variables involved in the
factor f so it's this factor so the
variables are y 1 and y 2 but we have to
keep Z s to its value I so in other
words we have to send the messages for
each value of I where we do the sum and
we take the variable to which we're
sending a message and we're keeping it
to that specified value I and otherwise
for the other variables we sum over
their values so in this case we're
sending to Y 2 so we're going to sum
over the value of y 1 so we have the sum
over Y 1 of this factor so the factor
here which is the pairwise factor so
it's the exponential of the pairwise
factor here times all the messages that
comes from other variable nodes as prime
that are not s in other words sent to F
so essentially this message here so that
message here so I have the exponential
of au y 1 times the exponential of AP y1
y2 so that's equivalent to the
exponential of a y1 and AP y 1 y 2 and
then we're summing over the other
variables that are not y2 so that's in
this case y1 and so that's this message
that's being sent from that factor to
this variable node removes a mink oh and
notice that this is actually the initial
value of the first column in the
computation of the alpha table in the
forward backward outlet so we see we're
starting to recover
pieces from the forward-backward album
next we could send the message from here
to there so with a similar reasoning as
in this case here we get one and with a
similar reasoning the message from this
factor to this variable node would just
be the exponential of the unary factor
for the position 2 in the sequence now
the message sends from y2 to this factor
this pairwise factor so we are in this
rule here s to F would be the product of
all the messages from other factors F
Prime's that are not F and that are
connected to s so it's the product of
that message and that message which is
this expression here or equivalently
alpha on y2 we'll use our notation from
the forward backward algorithm which we
find here it's the product of this time
step and now if we compute the message
to y3 then again what we get is the sum
over the other variable that shares the
same factor so that's why two of the
pairwise Factor here times all the
messages that were sent to all the
messages that were sent to F from a
variable known as prime which is
connected to F and which is not s so in
this case it would be it would be that
message here so we see that we have a
sum over Y to the other variable node of
the exponential of a to y2 which is here
times alpha 1 y2 which is here and times
the exponential of the pairwise factor
which we can just put into the same
exponential here and so this corresponds
to the pairwise factor in this
expression here corresponds to this
factor so if you continue like this
in this sequence in this order of the
messages we actually recover all of the
equations for the values of the outfit
so the column in the alpha tables and so
so this is just you know at the
beginning of the demonstration that
there are equivalent and you know full
demonstration will actually show you
that and so will validate that belief
propagation apply from left to right and
then right to left actually yields the
computation of all the alpha table and
then the computation of the beta table
so yeah so actually if you look at this
we actually do recover the expression
for the second column of the alpha table
and so by proceeding like this we
recover all the other table columns so
yeah and for the to sum up for the
linear chain a linear chain graph belief
propagation is actually the same as the
forward backward algorithm the forward
pass computes the Alpha table the
backward pass the better table for the
similar reason for numerical stability
we actually usually implement a version
that passes log messages so that's going
to be more stable numerically and one
advantage of the message passing
algorithm is that the belief propagation
algorithm is that we can do inference
now on other types of structure now
interestingly belief propagation yields
exact inference if are the structure of
our factor graph is a tree an arbitrary
tree actually so if we so we can show
that belief propagation actually
eventually converges by computing the if
we compute the each of the messages
eventually the messages stop changing
and and they actually correspond to what
you would like the messages to be so if
you log space the locks some of the
factors for all of the variables that's
come from
a given part of the tree and so these
log messages can be used then to provide
do approximate inference and in
particular compute marginals the general
algorithm with the same equations can
also be applied to a graph which has
loops so in this case it would not
correspond to a tree and and then it's
often used in practice to do approximate
inference so obtain some approximate
estimates of what the marginals could be
you have to be careful however the
algorithm could diverge so there are
certain tricks that are used to make it
converge so I you know this there's a
vast body of literature on message
passing algorithms and loopy belief
propagation which I won't cover but so
one trick that is tough time sometimes
uses that instead of updating the
messages by overriding them you instead
when you recompute a message at the
second password you computing the same
message a second time you actually do
some sort of weighted average between
the current message and the previous
message that's one trick that's used for
having a better behaved algorithm so I'm
not going to the detail in part because
there are actually a lot of
general-purpose libraries that are
publicly available where we just pass
the graph in a certain data structure
and then the algorithm will do this
message passing to a belief propagation
we'll run it over your graph and and
these are reals quite useful because
then they can be used on arbitrary types
of graphs so it means that now instead
of constraining ourselves to a linear
chain CRF before doing a sequential
classification we could start
considering adding lateral connections
between labels that are at two positions
away from each other so I have factors
between YK and YK plus two so even if
this would introduce some loops in the
in the model we could still deal with
those we could add all
so lateral connections for Triplets of
labels as well so really we can just
explore a bunch of different types of
graphs by adding factors as we wish and
then from these factors we get a factor
graph and from the factor graph this
would describe the way of passing
messages between variable notes and fat
log n factors and from factors to
variable notes so the idea really is
when we do CRF modeling is that you want
to add connections between the things
that have dependencies are fairly strong
that you want to model directly and in
fact you can have a connectivity that
varies between examples so if you have
some information that the first between
examples which would tell you that for
one example for instance the first label
should really be connected to the last
label for instance but for other maybe
for other structures you don't want this
you could actually have a separate
essentially graph separate factor graph
for each training example when you're
actually and you could actually train
such a CRF as well so examples of graphs
that we often see for a computer vision
we could have a grid structure so
imagine we were labeling each pixel in
image by maybe a segmentation label
which tells us which maybe separates
foreground from background well then we
if wanted to the labeling to be fairly
smooth we could have factors between
each pair of pixels like this that are
adjacent in the grid of pixels so that
the labeling is somewhat smooth
spatially but really in general we could
have any set of variables connected with
a bunch of different factors in this
case only showing pair of factors that
are over pairs of variables they but
they could be over Triplets or more and
then the loopy belief propagation
algorithm could be applied also on these
types of graphs
you have to be careful and doesn't like
I said loopy belief propagation or
belief propagation on loopy graphs is
not this little guarantee to converge
unless you're careful that's not
something I'm going to cover but I
encourage you to look at the literature
if you have you encounter problems where
you actually want these more complicated
structure to model your problem and
finally I just want to show the
expression for what to do with these
messages so intuitively these messages
correspond to what is the sum of all the
variable nodes that's that's are not the
current variable node that come from a
certain direction from the graph and so
if we wanted to compute the marginal
probability of a label somewhere in the
graph well to get its approximated
marginal that approximated marginal
would just take similarly as we've done
before the exponential of the log factor
that involves only that variable and
then plus the messages that come from
all the factors that involve the node YK
except the factor that's the the factor
that only involves YK if you have some
and we just sum the log messages from
these other factors from other nodes
outside of the in from other sorry for
other factor nodes that are connected to
this variable nodes we'd sum all of
their log messages and then we just
normalized the numerator by summing over
all values that are possible for my
variable of interests of the numerator
so the exponential exponentiate sum of
luck factors and log messages so to sum
up approximate inference would
correspond to summing over all the log
factors that involve only the variable
of interest YK so this is this term here
in this example I'm showing just one log
factor but you have you can have more
than one then you sum over all the log
messages that come into YK from other
factors
so it's this sum here then
and you take the egg spinach the
exponential of those sum of log factors
and log messages and then we normalize
by to ensure that we get a valid
distribution okay so this sums up the
general belief propagation algorithm for
general conditional random fields